let's say we've got some function f that
is continuous over the interval between
c and d and the reason why i'm using c
and d instead of a and b is so i can use
a and b for later and let's say we set
up some function capital f of x which is
defined as the area under the curve
between c
and some value x where x is in this
interval where where f is continuous uh
under the curve so it's the area under
the curve between c and x so if this is
x right over here under the curve f of t
dt so this right over here f of x is
that area that right over there is what
f x is now the fundamental
theorem of calculus tells us that if f
is continuous over this interval
then
f of x is differentiable at every x in
the interval and the derivative the
derivative of capital f of x and let me
see let me be clear
capital f of x is differentiable at
every possible x between c and d and the
derivative of capital f of x is going to
be equal to lowercase
f of x
fair enough now what i want to do in
this video is connect the first
fundamental theorem of calculus to the
second part or the second fundamental
theorem of calculus which we tend to use
to actually evaluate definite integrals
so let's think about
let's think about what f of
f of b
what f of b
minus
f of a is what this is where both b and
a are also in this interval so f of b
and we're going to assume that b is
larger than a so let's say that b is
this right over here let me do that the
same color
so let's say that b
is right over here f of b
is going to be equal to we just
literally replace the b where you see
the x it's going to be equal to the
definite integral between c
and b
of f of t
dt which is just another way of saying
it's just another way of saying is the
area under the curve between c and b
so this f of b
capital f of b
is all of this business
all of this business right over here and
from that we are going to want to
subtract we are going to subtract
capital f of a which is just the
integral between c and lowercase a of
lowercase f of t
dt so let's say that this is
let's say that this is a right over here
capital f of a is just literally the
area between c and a under the curve
lowercase f of t
so it's this right over here
it's all of this business
all of this
right over here
so what is if you have this blue area
which is all of this and you subtract
out this red this this this this magenta
area what are you left with well you're
left with this green area you're left
with this green area right over here and
how would we represent that how would we
denote that well we could denote that as
the definite integral between a
and b
of f of t
dt
and there you have it this right over
here is the second fundamental theorem
of calculus it tells us that this
if f is continuous on the interval that
this is going to be equal to the
antiderivative or an antiderivative of f
and we see right over here that capital
f is the antiderivative of f so that we
could view this as capital f anti
antiderivative this as this is how we
defined capital f the anti-derivative or
we didn't define it that way but the
fundamental theorem of calculus tells us
that capital f is an antiderivative of
lowercase f so right over here this
tells you if you have a definite
integral like this it completely
equivalent to an anti-derivative of it
evaluated at f and from that evaluated
at b and from that you subtract it
evaluated at a so normally it looks like
this i just switched the order
the definite integral from a to b
of f of t
dt is equal to an antiderivative of f so
capital f evaluated at b and from that
the antiderivative
from that subtract the antiderivative
evaluated at a and this is the second
part of the fundamental theorem of
calculus or the second fundamental
theorem of calculus and it's really the
core of an integral calculus class
because it's how you actually evaluate
definite integrals